داها في البحر فا انقذه الكاتشب
لم يكن لديه سوى زجاجه كاتشب واحده ومسحوق
من الثوم وقطع المرق خلطها بالماء ليكون
هذا الخليط السبب في بقائه حيه
التائه في ظلمات البحار
فما الذي حدث مع هذا الرجل
القصه بدات عندما كان فرانسوا يجلس على
الشاطئ قباله ميناء في جزيره سانت مارتن
الكاريبيه كان يصلح مركبه الشرعيه
الوقت في يوم كان عصيبا جدا فالطقس وقتها
ساءت حالته انهامك فرانسوا في تصليح قاربه
الشراعي وتجريبه ولسوء حظه جرفته المياه
الغاذره لمصير المجهول
24 يوما قضاها في عرض البحر
لم يكن قادرا على العوده الى بلده كان
ينتظر مصيره المجهول لكن ماء المطر الذي
كان يتعاطل عليه باستمرار طيله ايام عزلته
بعرض البحر كان السبب في بقاء جسمه فقط
كان يخلط تلك القطارات مع ما لديه من طعام
بسيط وير ومنهم كل يوم شيء قليلا املا
ومتمسكا بفراس بقائه حيه
[موسيقى]
على القارب ومسحوق الثوم ومكعبات مرق
الدجاج
خلطتها ببعض الماء
لا احب اتحدث معه لا اعرف ما يجب القيام
به لا اعرف اين انا لقد كانت تجربه قاسيه
وفقدت الامل في مرحله ما
سينما فرنسوا من فرص البقاء على قيد
الحياه ففكر في اي حيله او طريقه للوصول
الى اليابسه استعان بمراه كانت بحوزته
وبدا من خلال انعكاس اشعه الشمس عليها
بارسال اشارات لكل طائره تمر من فوقه وليس
هذا فقط فرنسوا ونحت ايضا كلمه المساعده
على هيكل قاربه املا بان يعثر احد عليه
وينقذه
نجحت خطط هذا الرجل وكانت هذه الطائره فوق
امله الاخيره
فرنسوا شوهد من طائره بعد ان كتب كلمه
مساعده على جسم القارب وبالفعل تم التواصل
مع سفينه تجاريه كانت تبحر بالقرب
ونقلته الى ميناء كارتخنه تلقى الرعايه
الطبيه وتم تسليمه لاحقا الى سلطات الهجره
من اجل عودته الى بلاده
تم انقاذ فرنسا في نهايه المطاف بعد قضائه
24 يوما وعلى بعد نحو 120 ميلا بحريا شمال
غرب شبه جزيره في اقصى شمال امريكا
الجنوبيه
سيبقى مدينه للقدر ثم لعلبه من الكاتشب
التي كانت سببا في بقائه حيه
[موسيقى]